[Музика]
привіт, привіт усім, настав час
уроку англійської мови, мене звати Наталія
Ешкомб, давайте почнемо
сьогодні, ми поговоримо про
обліковий запис у соціальних мережах та створення облікового запису в соціальних
мережах, давайте почнемо, тому подивіться
на картинку, що тут відбувається, я
можу  бачиш хлопчика підлітка та леді, то
хто ця жінка,
вона не схожа на його дівчину,
вона занадто стара для дівчини, тож, мабуть,
мама, що ти думаєш, щоб вони
працювали з ноутбуком, і я бачу цей
значок  людей і слова, які говорять привіт
, схоже, вони обговорюють соціальні
мережі, тому що у нас є люди,
і з взаємодією кажуть привіт тому
хто кому допомагає підліток допомагає
своїй мамі чи мама допомагає своєму синові
давайте подивимося на текст виглядає  помиляєтесь і
дізнайтеся, хто кому допомагає, ви
абсолютно праві, тому син Стів допомагає
своїй мамі створити обліковий запис у соціальних мережах,
і у нас є кілька фраз, і нам потрібно
закінчити діалог цими фразами,
давайте спочатку подивимося на них, що  's
next, тому ми запитуємо, який буде
наступний напрямок, це все, тому ми
закінчуємо, щоб побачити, що вам потрібно, тому, коли
вам потрібна допомога, ви попросіть її, а
запит: що нам потрібно, що ви
хочете, щоб я  зробіть, як це зробити,
тому мені потрібні інструкції, а потім натисніть кнопку
зареєструватися для нового облікового запису, щоб це була
конструкція AK, а остання така ж
проста, тому у нас є шість речень,
але нам потрібно лише п’ять, одне додаткове, яке ми
не маємо  не потрібно, давайте перейдемо до діалогу
та почнемо читати одну за одною та додавати
фрази, тож, Стів, у тебе є хвилинка,
мамо, що буде далі, що тобі
точно потрібно, тож давайте прочитаємо ще раз, звичайно,
мама, що тобі потрібно, і вони відповідають  Я
хочу зв'язатися з деякими старими
шкільними друзями, чи можете ви допомогти мені створити
обліковий запис у соціальних мережах добре, це легко,
спершу перейдіть на веб-сайт
служби соціальних мереж, до якої ви
хочете приєднатися, що буде далі, у нас є п'ять
варіантів, виберіть один  так, тоді натисніть
зареєструватися для нового облікового запису, тож давайте ще
раз прочитаємо  Стів слова добре, це легко,
спершу перейдіть на веб-сайт
соціальної мережі, до якої ви
хочете приєднатися, а потім натисніть кнопку зареєструватися для
нового облікового запису, гаразд.
так що добре, я зробив, що далі,
тепер вам потрібно ввести інформацію, яку він
запитує, і вибрати ім’я користувача добре зрозуміло,
він каже, що мені потрібно створити
пароль – так, як тільки ви це зробите,
ви готові шукати свій  шкільні
друзі та надішліть їм запити на друзів,
що буде далі
так, як мені це зробити, послухайте мене, як
це зробити, просто натисніть кнопку знайти
друга та введіть їх імена,
що буде далі.
тож давайте ще раз прочитаємо слова Стіва, просто
натисніть кнопку «Визначити» і
введіть їх назви,
це так просто, дякую за вашу
допомогу, Стіве, без проблем, мамо
, це все зайве, нам це не потрібно
, тепер давайте прочитаємо діалог  знову ти
можеш слідувати за мною, Стів  у тебе є хвилинка,
мамо,
що тобі потрібно. Я хочу зв'язатися
з друзями зі старої школи
хочу приєднатися, а потім
натисніть зареєструватися для нового облікового запису добре
я зробив, що далі, тепер вам
потрібно ввести інформацію, яку він запитує, і
вибрати ім'я користувача добре зрозумів, він говорить,
що мені потрібно створити пароль - так
як тільки ви це зробите, ви готові
шукати своїх шкільних друзів і надсилати
їм запити на друзів, і як це зробити
, просто натисніть кнопку «Знайти друга
» та введіть їх ім’я, це так
просто, дякую за вашу допомогу,
Стів  не проблема, мамо, тож давайте попрацюємо з
деякими фразами, подивіться, у нас є
два стовпці дієслова та
вирази, тож давайте об’єднаємо їх, щоб
завершити фрази, давайте подивимося
на цю частину фотографію, яку ви хочете надіслати
у свої програми,
що таке слова  програми ви пам'ятаєте
ми обговорювали це на першому уроці,
коли ми говорили про гаджети, тож
програми, це програми, скільки
програм у вас на мобільному телефоні, у мене
є, наприклад, 20, а як щодо вас п’ять десять
двадцять, добре, наступний значок галереї
Я можу це невелике зображення  який
показує вам тип програми,
номер ваших друзів,
як легко поділитися фотографією, тому давайте почнемо
з першого і перейдіть до ваших
програм, повторюйте за мною,
перейдіть до ваших програм, зараз давайте спробуємо
іншу ітерацію, перейдіть до ваших програм
або перейдіть до  ваші програми, коли ми ставимо
запитання, ми зазвичай піднімаємось, щоб перейти до
ваших програм, а відповідь — вниз, перейдіть до
номера ваших програм, щоб натиснути, тому клацніть
значок «Галерея», щоб ви побачили зображення,
і ви клацнете на ньому, повторіть після того, як я
натисніть  на значку «Галерея» перейдемо
до інтонації питання клацніть на значку «
Галерея» клацніть на значку «Галерея»
виберіть, що ви можете вибрати так
виберіть фотографію, яку ви хочете надіслати,
повторіть за мною виберіть фотографію, яку ви
хочете надіслати із запитанням в
dona  виберіть фотографію, яку хочете
надіслати, і відповідь виберіть фотографію, яку
хочете надіслати, виберіть, як
поділитися фотографією,
повторіть за мною, виберіть, як поділитися
фотографією з інформацією про запитання так
правильно виберіть, як поділитися фотографією
та виберіть відповідь  як поділитися
фотографією, а останнє введіть,
що ви можете ввести номер свого друга
правильно, тому повторюйте за мною,
введіть ім'я свого друга,
введіть інтонацію питання в імені свого
друга та введіть відповідь у
імені свого друга завдання для  ви швидко
я приховую слова та допоможіть мені
завершити фрази,
щоб фотографія, яку ви хочете надіслати, виберіть
фотографію, яку ви хочете надіслати у свої програми, перейдіть
до своїх програм значок галереї натисніть
значок галереї виправте номер ваших друзів,
введіть номер вашого друга у вашому друга  номер і
як поділитися фотографією, я не пам'ятаю,
давайте подивимося та виберемо, як
поділитися фотографією. Браво,
ви чудово попрацювали, давайте йти далі, тому у нас
є 4 речення, допоможіть мені вибрати
правильний елемент  давайте подивимося на номер
1 Марія хоче створити обліковий запис у соцмережах або приєднатися до нього,
що ми робимо з
лічильником так, що ми створюємо, тому Марія хоче
створити обліковий запис у соціальних мережах, повторіть
ще раз номер 2 виберіть або натисніть
кнопку Зберегти, щоб ви не  не втратити свою роботу
так, натисніть на повторити після мене натисніть
кнопку Зберегти, щоб не втратити свою
роботу номер 3
Джо забув підписати або ввести своє
ім'я користувача та пароль підписати або ввести
правильну відповідь введіть Джо забув
ввести  його ім'я користувача та пароль, і я
маю запитання до вас, як часто ви
забуваєте ввести свій пароль та
ім'я користувача. Я постійно забуваю свій власний
пароль, і їм потрібно знову і знову звільнятися,
на жаль, номер
4 останнє запитання, яке ви повинні знайти або
виберіть відео, яким ви хочете поділитися,
і правильна відповідь - виберіть, тому повторюйте
за мною, ви повинні вибрати відео
, яким хочете поділитися, або ви повинні
вибрати телефон
, яким хочете поділитися, давайте рухаємося далі, у нас
є запитання та відповіді, тому дозвольте  '  s
приєднатися до цих двох колонок, що далі, тепер
вам потрібно правильно написати їхню сукню.
Я натискаю на пісок праворуч, що
буде далі, що логічно, якщо
людина реагує або підтверджує
інформацію, використовуючи правильне запитання, тому
ми підтверджуємо, так, чи точно у вас є  через
хвилину наступне запитання має бути, звичайно,
що вам потрібно, щоб людина
просила допомоги, ми допомагаємо, наступний крок
– прикріпити файл, як це зробити,
як прикріпити файл, чи можете ви допомогти мені
надіслати електронний лист  добре, це легко, тож давайте
подивимося на фрази ще раз, і
запитання зникнуть, ми бачимо у
відповіді, і вони дають вам 10 секунд,
швидко подумайте над запитаннями, а тепер
давайте перевіримо, тому першому, тепер вам
потрібно написати його сукню, яке було
запитання, чи  запам'ятати, що далі,
так, якою була фраза, зараз я натискаю
на пісок праворуч, звичайно, що вам потрібно
, у вас є хвилинка,
правильно, як мені зробити, що наступний крок
- правильно прикріпити файл, а
останній добре, це добре  sy, яке було
запитання, чи можете ви допомогти мені надіслати електронний лист
добре, це легко, тож давайте подивимося ще на
один приклад діалогу
подивіться на картинку у нас немає жінки, у
нас є джентльмен, літня людина
і молодий джентльмен a  хлопчик, що
тут відбувається, я бачу, що, ймовірно, цей
хлопець - його дідусь, і він
тримає мобільний телефон або смартфон, мабуть,
хм, якщо я думаю про перший приклад,
то, ймовірно, це подібна
ситуація, коли Стів допоміг своїй мамі, зараз цей
хлопець збирається  допоможи своєму дідусеві
давайте подивимося на текст, що тут відбувається,
тож тато Грем сказав мені, кому потрібна
допомога,
дідусю, і в чому проблема, добре,
тепер у нас є фрази, і нам потрібно
додати їх до діалогу, давайте
подивимося на  фрази натисніть що, щоб
підключитися до їх Wi-Fi, натисніть те, щоб
підключитися до їх Wi-Fi перейдіть до ваших програм
далі ми вже обговорювали, що
перейти до ваших додатків означає перейти до ваших програм
знайти програму, яку вам
потрібно просто натиснути підключити,
щоб  натиснути кон  натисніть кнопку просто введіть
номер вашої кімнати та прізвище, введіть
своє ім'я користувача та пароль, які ми мали цього
разу, у нас є номер кімнати та прізвище,
підключіть мій телефон до готелю Wi-Fi перейдіть
до налаштувань, а потім Wi-Fi, щоб
вибрати останній  пароль,
ситуація насправді відбувається в готелі, і
вони хочуть звернути вашу увагу, оскільки у
нас урок розмови, будь ласка,
вимовте слово готель правильно
це не готель це готель і подумайте
про українські слова або готель, який ми
не знаємо  скажи, що
це не так, тому готель у готелі той же,
будь ласка, будьте обережні, щоб у нас було шість фраз
- зайва, яка нам не потрібна, давайте
почнемо з ранку діалогу Томмі, чи можеш
ти допомогти мені з чимось,
звичайно, дідусю, що тобі потрібно, я
хочу -  мм-хм, щоб я міг вийти в Інтернет, яка
фраза є найбільш підходящою так правильно
підключіть мій телефон до Wi-Fi готелю, тож
давайте повторимо цю фразу
ще раз я хочу підключити свій телефон
до Wi-Fi готелю, щоб я міг вийти в Інтернет  добре
,
спочатку легко  з усіх la la la la яка
правильна відповідь
так, перейдіть до налаштувань, а потім Wi-Fi, тож
давайте повторимо фразу Томмі ще раз о
, це легко,
спочатку перейдіть до налаштувань, а потім
Wi-Fi добре я зробив це, що
далі  шукайте готель у
списку доступних мереж, які вам потрібні - la la
la la яка правильна відповідь
допоможіть мені так правильно натисніть це щоб
підключитися до Wi-Fi давайте повторимо
фразу ще раз, тепер шукайте готель
у списку доступних  мережі, вам
потрібно натиснути це, щоб підключитися до Wi-Fi,
добре зрозуміло, він говорить, що мені потрібно ввести
пароль, щоб правильною відповіддю було б
просто ввести номер вашої кімнати та
повторювати прізвище за мною,
просто введіть номер вашої кімнати та
прізвище добре
я  Я ввів, гм, це те, що майже ви
ла-ла-ла-ла, і ви в цьому, так що
тут найбільше підходить, так,
просто потрібно натиснути підключитися, тому
давайте повторимо фразу Томмі знову майже, вам
потрібно просто натиснути підключитися, і ви перебуваєте в
Wow I  Я підключений, що було легко
завдяки тону без проблем, дідусь  d, отже,
це дві фрази, які нам не потрібні, перейдіть до
ваших програм і виберіть пароль зараз,
давайте прочитаємо весь діалог, слідкуйте за мною,
будь ласка,
ранок, Томмі, чи можете ви допомогти мені з
чимось,
звичайно, дідусю, що вам потрібно, я
хочу підключити свій  телефонуйте до готелю
Wi-Fi, щоб я міг виходити в Інтернет о, це легко,
спочатку перейдіть до налаштувань, а потім
Wi-Fi все добре я зробив, що
далі, тепер шукайте готель у
списку доступних мереж, потрібно натиснути
що щоб підключитися до їхнього Wi-Fi, добре зрозумів,
він говорить, що мені потрібно ввести пароль, просто
введіть номер вашої кімнати та прізвище,
добре,
я ввів їх, це все, що вам майже
потрібно просто натиснути підключитися і сечі вау,
я підключений  це було легко,
дякую, Томе, без проблем, дідусю, тепер
є завдання для тебе, давайте відповімо на
запитання номер один добре, то що
мені тепер робити, і є дві
можливі відповіді, клацніть на піктограмі, це так
само легко, як правильна
так, це я клацніть по значку, клацніть
по значку, другий q  У вас є
хвилина,
яка була легкою або, звичайно, яка
найбільш підходяща відповідь так правильно,
звичайно, ви хочете, щоб я допоміг я готовий
допомогти, у вас є хвилина, звичайно,
і останнє запитання, тож як мені додати
зображення профілю перша зупинка
або a поруч із зображенням OB перш за
все виберіть гарну фотографію Я думаю, що це так
само легко, як і те, що B правильно,
спочатку виберіть гарне фото, а потім почніть
завантажувати фотографію, ця карта розмов
може допомогти вам  щоб створити власні діалекти,
вам знадобиться це для домашнього завдання, тож
давайте вивчимо карту, у нас є двоє людей, які
розмовляють a і B перший приклад a була
мамою, а B був сином, другий приклад
a був дідусем, а B був онуком, тому
ці  двоє людей розмовляють,
давайте подивимося на розмову, тому a завжди
починайте запитувати B, чи є у них вільний час,
що ви робите для цього, чи можете ви мені допомогти,
що у вас є хвилина, B має
відповісти та запитати, що їм, звичайно, потрібно
що вам потрібно або так, впевнені, що вам
потрібно так a  потрібно сказати, що ви
хочете зробити, або запитати B, чи можуть вони допомогти вам
із проблемою, яку ви маєте, B повинен
відповісти і дати першу інструкцію, а потім
ace підтвердити, що вони це зробили, і
попросити наступну інструкцію, що ви робите
для цього  Я зробив те, що далі, о, я
пройшов через те, що наступне B
дає другу інструкцію, а потім
потрібно розповісти, що UPS має робити
далі, щоб
потім пояснити, що це означає, щоб
вони могли допомогти  потім ace спитай, що робити
далі, і базова відповідь,
розповість a, як зробити наступний крок, і,
нарешті, подяка B за допомогу та B
і розмова. Я прошу
вас використовувати цю карту, щоб створити
власне діалогове вікно як домашнє завдання  Ваш літній
родич хоче надіслати
фотографію на телефон своїх друзів, їм потрібна
допомога, скористайтеся наведеними нижче фразами, щоб створити
діалог, а фрази, які ми маємо, переходять
у ваші програми, натисніть значок галереї,
виберіть фотографію, яку ви хочете надіслати, виберіть,
як  поділіться фотографією  і введіть номер свого
друга, ми використовуємо ці фрази
раніше на уроці, запам'ятайте, щоб це
могло допомогти вам наступного уроку ми
почнемо з цього діалогу, будьте готові,
на жаль, є дзвіночок, який нам потрібно
закінчити урок, дуже дякую
до побачення
[Музика]
ти